no well I hope there aren't too many
people in the pet you don't want to be
in that path that's a path you don't
want to be in and we tried to warn
everybody and for the most part they've
left but that's a bad path to be in
[Music]
this is a life-threatening situation
take this deadly storm seriously
[Applause]
[Music]
overnight the moment florida had braced
irma hid land and the Sunshine State
went dark
thousands hunkered down in shelters and
sports stadiums to ride it out animals
were taken to a safe place this was too
much rain too much water even for the
two-legged variety there was a mandatory
evacuation order in parts of Florida but
some decided to stay put
building here is though in 67
it's pre-stressed concrete slabs on
poured concrete walls so we feel pretty
confident we've been through a lot of
storms in that hurricane Willman we had
to water come up to the second set of
block we're anticipating the same thing
to happen boats would tied down and
fingers were crossed the authorities it
being quite clear that they show the
danger to life and and that's
understandable and that that really is
the truth for most most locations but at
13 and a half foot of elevation with
another 10 feet on top of that plus the
fact that the building is so strong
that's our advantage
Key West was wet on the first major
even sturdy historic monuments like the
Castillo de San Marcos in San Augustine
couldn't escape mother nature in Naples
further up the coast water levels rose
by two meters in just 90 minutes
fort myers was next in it
fog swirled around skyscrapers and roads
were flooded
[Music]
this is the situation right now around
breckel Bay the water from the bay has
started to go inside the building since
the lobby of the building but it's
really pretty dangerous I should be
honest nobody should let me out nobody
in Tampa as in much of Florida the
streets were deserted
water has sucked out of the harbor by
the storm a misleading prelude thought
was about to come the authorities were
worried about a storm surge I've never
seen nothing like this I think we're
pretty prepared for it and our houses
all boarded up and everything just about
the wind mostly in trees coming down
we're up and in activation level see so
I'm not really worried about the water
up there but just the wind and trees we
were just a little curious to see what
the water level was like and how things
were down here and get outside before we
have to hunker down here by the time it
reached the city the hurricane had lost
some of its power but none of its
fearsome reputation
Irma made landfall on the southern
shores of Florida early on Sunday
evening as it approached the state it
increased in strength and changed
direction
Miami was spared a direct hit the
Florida Keys were hit hard though with
winds of a hundred and thirty miles per
hour as she progressed she gradually
downgraded to a category 1 storm with
winds of 75 miles per hour as it moves
along Florida's west coast by the
morning the center of the storm was
about 60 miles north of Tampa moving
north towards Georgia and weakening into
a tropical storm the for Florida Cuba
took a battering it proved to be a cruel
few hours for the island not only to
Dermer change track to smash into the
northern coast
she also suddenly gained strength as
well 170 mile per hour winds and heavy
rain caused heaven
this is the British Virgin Islands
virtually no home has been undamaged
infrastructure has been ripped apart
[Music]
it's like a war zone the house is gone
it's flattened people are just wandering
around carrying whatever they've got in
their hand
it's truly surrender one eyewitness has
described the BVI is Ground Zero another
resident thinks it will take a year or
more to rebuild power lines are down
wireless power is degree everywhere
people walking around homeless someday
the hospital has also been badly damaged
the doctor on holiday in Spain has been
in touch with colleagues there they were
still Smurfs are still some of my
colleagues that are unaccounted for and
they've heard nothing from we don't know
if they survived the kind of people that
they would have been straight there to
help
more British aid has been flown out by
the RAF today medical equipment and
heavy lifting gear 120 prisoners on the
island escaped during the hurricane and
so officers from the Metropolitan Police
have also gone to the British Virgin
Islands to help with law and order the
scale of the devastation is
unprecedented so of course people are
experiencing great hardship and our job
right now is to make sure that we can
alleviate that hardship through the
response on the ground getting food
water hygiene shelter to people that
desperately need it and we aren't doing
that but obviously the need is great and
we're constantly replenishing supplies
on the island of San Martin troops now
patrol the streets of the territory this
was one of the worst-hit two people were
killed here and more than 40 injured the
island is jointly administered by the
French and the Dutch this footage was
filmed by Marines from the Netherlands
military there are now 200 extra troops
on the island helping to deliver aid and
restore order amid reports of looting a
few hundred people have also been
evacuated to Guadeloupe including
Johanna Cardona who gave birth the day
after the hurricane struck it's Julia II
I was in the house during the storm it
was horrible
the hosts fell apart no it's war in Sint
Maarten for food water there's no
electricity no air nothing
[Music]
the Bahamas is counting its blessings
the storm hit but it was a glancing blow
and it has merged largely unscathed the
holiday nation has been spared the
ordeal that befell is Caribbean
neighbors they prayed for mercy and
those prayers were answered this is what
it did to the Turks and Caicos Islands
though I was inside when I see to my
skimming my BOB ten o'clock I got to run
and I fall down all my hand pulls up and
I lost everything Florida of course has
been here before at this hour were
issuing a hurricane warning for the
southeast coast of Florida extending
from Vero Beach southward through the
Florida Keys
Hurricane Andrew devastated Miami County
in 1992 killing more than 60 people and
destroying a hundred and twenty five
thousand homes on the left this is what
Andrew looked like 25 years ago
irma is the storm on the right it dwarfs
it this was the scene in Tampa as it
woke up at the beginning of a new week
[Applause]
people are starting to return home
cautiously one of the first tasks will
be to restore power 5.7 million homes
across Florida without electricity
we are still of course worried about the
storm surge and the heavy rain that will
be associated with what is left of Emma
so that the next drop down from a
category one would be to a tropical
storm and those are bad enough that a
tropical depression and we're looking at
it going into the mountainous areas of
Georgia South Carolina Alabama and on
into Tennessee it will be dropping about
four or five inches of rain and when you
drop that kind of rain in a mountainous
area flash flooding of course is a
problem we are also forecasting winds
upwards of 50 miles per hours so you can
expect wind damage shingles coming up
roofs things like that
after days of nervous waiting Irma is
finally dying out
[Music]
she's been downgraded to a tropical
storm
[Music]
the strongest hurricane in history
hasn't quite flown it's last and it has
done its worst
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]